الان معنا دحجازي واقفه مع هذه المساله
التي كانت حديث الساعات الماضيه في مصر
بعد عرض حلقه مسلسل الهرشه السابعه ندى
اليك اهلا بك
[موسيقى]
مساء الخير يا نادين مساء الخير يا سهام
هو مسلسل هرشا السابعه من اكثر المسلسلات
اللي حققت راند خلال الشهر يعني كل يوم
الحلقه بتاعه المسلسل هي ترند وده راجع
لان في ناس كثير قوي شايفه انه ده يعني
مسلسل بيعكس الواقع بشكل كبير جدا وشبه
حياه ناس كتير جدا لحد يخوف طبعا فكره
المسلسل انه
بيبين قد ايه بعد سبع سنين
المسؤوليات
والضغوطات بتبين العلاقه دي ممكن تستمر
ولا لا لانه بتتغير شخصيه الزوجين
في الحلقه اللي فاتت في جمله هي
يعني ضايقت ستات كثير قوي وهي الجمله
بتاعت محمد شاهين وهو بيقول انا مش دوري
ان انا اقعد اربي العيال
للاسف ده جزء كبير قوي من الواقع في اسر
كثير يعني في كثير عندنا رجاله بيبقوا
شايفين انه تربيه الاطفال دي هي مسئوليه
الست وانا دوري ان انا اصرف عليهم بس
فنتيجه
الضغط ده او انه ده جزء من واقع اسر كتير
الجمله دي داست عند على على الحته اللي
ضايقتهم فستات كثير بدات ان هي تعرض
الثقافه
الخارجيه اللي ممكن تبقى مش عندنا بس ليه
ما تبقاش عندنا مساله رجاله بتختار انه هي
تقعد تربي العيال يعني هي الستات بس
تضايقت من فكره راجل يعني اللي يقعد في
البيت بس مثلا بيقول لك كمان المسلسل انه
جميع الرجال يقدمون على خيانه زوجاتهم في
السنه السابعه من الزواج
وهذا ايضا يثير جدل كبير في مصر اليوم
وحتى في العالم اكيد يعني نتحدث عن سبع
سنين دام ما استوقفش حد يا ندى
لا استوقف طبعا ناس كتير جدا وناس كثير
قوي انتقدت احداث المسلسل
علشان المسلسل مش حلو انتقدوها لانها
بتعكس الواقع في فعلا رجاله كتير بتعمل
كده بعد الوقت ده بسبب الضغط والجدل قائم
من الطرفين يعني هتلاقي الرجاله بتدافع
قوي عن ادم والستات بتدافع قوي عن نادين
يعني شايفين انه انت تخونها ليه هي في
الاخر متحمله ضغطه اطفال ومتحمله ضغط
الحياه اللي فيها عبء كبير قوي على الست
في مصر وانت مش عايز تشاركها ده لان انت
شايف ان ده مش دورك فانه ليه ليه يعني ليه
انت مش دورك تقعد تربي العيال طب ما في
بره رجاله بتقعد تربي العيال في البيت ده
مش مش عيب ومش واصمه بس طبعا علشان احنا
ده حاجه مش متعودين عليها
فهاجبنا الفكره بقوه لكن انا اعتقد ان
ممكن في يوم من الايام بعد مسلسل زي ده
وبعد فتح المناقشه دي ممكن نشوف بعد كده
رجاله ربي اكيد بنوضح نادين المسلسل انت
ما بتكلميني اصلا نوضح للناس شكرا جزيلا
لك ندى حجازي واقفه مع هذه المساله
التي كانت اثارت جدل في مصر